we got a crazy report coming out of
Florida apparently a media consultant
and an and a Democrat have been raided
by the FBI in connection with leaked uh
videos from Tucker Carlson apparently it
went to Vice news and media matters so
uh we'll we'll break the story down and
and see what we got going on here but uh
I just think it's surprising that the
the FBI went after a Democrat I just
couldn't believe it so maybe this was
more embarrassing to them or something I
don't know but we do we do got a bunch
of other news
okay bud light has uh teamed up with
Harley Davidson I know it's bad news or
I'm sorry Budweiser did and then Bud
Light is sponsoring a pride event so
they're just doubling down and uh yeah
it's Friday night man we're chilling we
got some leaked audio from a DeSantis
fundraiser I think it's worth what was
it was a was it a fundraiser or
something like that I don't know we'll
talk about that it's really interesting
they basically say that once they get
into the middle of campaign season
DeSantis is going to go full moderate
and safe legal and rare on abortion
which I found very very interesting so
before we get started my friends head
over to castbrew.com and become a cast
member of the cast Brew Coffee Club if
you want to purchase you get to several
bags of coffee every every month or you
can just buy our coffee directly we've
got some really uh really great new
products coming out we're going to be
launching a special Sheamus coffee blend
which uh the prices will go to Sheamus
a portion well we're doing a deal with
them and we're excited for that it's
gonna be really funny and this is our
coffee company we're sponsoring
ourselves if you want to support our
work go to casper.com buy the coffee
from us if you've got an office buy the
coffee for your office K-Cups are coming
very very soon and we're going to be
rolling out limited edition uh art and
bags and things like that so I'm really
excited for that also go to timcast.com
click join us become a member support
our work directly if you really want to
help us out you can also shout out the
show smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and a whole lot more is Alx thanks
for having me back who are you what do
you do
um I am a Twitter personality I guess
you could say but I also am Benny
Johnson's executive producer for his
podcast and I just live online so that's
that's about all I do right on well
thanks for joining us it should be fun
we got Taylor Silverman hanging out
what's up guys I'm Taylor Silverman I
work here at Tim Cass on the show Cass
castle and I also do a bit of traveling
around and talking about males invading
women's sports because this is something
I experienced in women's skateboarding
and I don't want other girls to have to
go through it and they are a lot a lot
of stories that people don't know about
there's a few that everyone knows and
countless ones in so many different
sports that you wouldn't even expect but
um I'm trying to raise awareness about
that and use my voice so we can bring
back fairness and equal opportunity and
safety
hello everyone I am philibonti from the
heavy metal band All That Remains I am
an anti-communist and a
counter-revolutionary and we are here
with
it's Kellen uh back this Friday Fridays
are the best days good to see you again
Alex
um yeah let's get rolling all right we
got the story from the Western Journal
Democrat lawmakers house raided by FBI
in connection to Tucker Carlson leaks
it's crazy the FBI search a Florida
Democrat elected official's home is
connected to leaked materials from Fox
News they say the federal agency
conducted a raid in search of a Tampa
home this month the Tampa Tampa Bay
Times reported the home is that of Tampa
Tampa city council member Lynn hertock
and her husband media consultant Tim
Burke
Carlson has been targeted in a series of
selective leaks following his firing
from Fox News last month with leftist
organization Media Matters publishing
off-air content in which he made
off-color remarks we had this from a
daily mail elaborating to say FBI
probe's hack of Fox News computers which
saw saw unaired footage from Tucker
Carlson's interview with Kanye West
leaked to Vice Florida media
consultant's home is searched as part of
the investigation
so they say in a May 25th letter
obtained by Daily Mail a federal
prosecutor in Tampa Florida alerted Fox
News to the criminal probe into stolen
material including unaired video of
Tucker Carlson who was fired in April
actually I don't think Tucker was fired
yet I know he wasn't fired right they
just heard a show off yeah he's still
actually an employee yeah and that's how
they're keeping him kind of you know
from doing other official shows is
exactly him on contract so here's the
crazy thing about this story the FBI
rated a Democrat why would they do that
I mean I I don't I question the motives
of the Democrat leaking this because all
of these leaks made him look better and
more relatable
no not these leaks uh a lot of people
right so there's two things to say the
leaks where Tucker is saying things you
know while they were prepping the show
or whatever
some of them we laugh at and like that's
silly and makes no doesn't mean anything
some of them it will just be negative
press the Democrats are going to Rally
around but the Kanye West leaks showed
that they did edit out certain comments
that perhaps they thought would be
offensive so either way I don't know the
idea matters ones were all hilarious
yeah and I think one of them was fake I
think the one where you said Fu Media
Matters looks like a deep fake
unfortunately but I don't know nowadays
you never know like the Deep fakes are
getting too good we're not gonna know
anything we're just going we're just
going blind into the future and
yeah I mean in the next year uh the
upcoming year is going to be
very strenuous on people I think because
people aren't going to know what to
believe it's gonna obviously you know
when you hear Joe Biden and Donald Trump
you know smack talking each other over
video games you know that yeah you know
made up but if it's a legitimate
you know speech that is you know similar
to something that any of the candidates
would say
I can't imagine this time next year that
the technology won't beat every single
human being there might be AI they can
pick them out but I feel like no about
that most human beings are going to be
like I couldn't tell the difference
that's only a year and that's in a year
because think about what AI was like a
year ago was there even
excuse me I don't even think that that
we had like a lot of AI stuff that was
getting out when it comes to like the
images and and chat yeah the problem is
it's training itself so the more the
more it progresses the more real it's
going to get and the issue is going to
be the audio leaks obviously like the
video ones are kind of easy to tell but
like say if there's leaked audio and
they claim it's leak audio from like a
fundraising event like you know the
DeSantis thing uh someone could claim
that it was leaked audio and then you
know a year from now you might not know
if it's actually real yeah so uh this
was last year
I used I think it was
um I don't even remember the name of the
AI I made AI generated images of trump
Biden and Pelosi and they were grotesque
looking and very fake and uh posted them
to Twitter so they're on my Twitter
somewhere
today when you go to Mid journey and and
type in Trump you get the it's it's real
it's it's there's no way to tell it's
not it's crazy I mean they've tried
they're probably uh as you're mentioning
some some software probably could drag
it down but I want to read this though
in the story that's interesting they
mentioned that this guy Burke who's
being rated that he's worked for
Deadspin and The Daily Beast and then
there's something interesting I see in
the story they say in a legal letter
published in Media Matters earlier this
month Fox asked the group not to publish
the to stop publishing this footage the
letter doesn't address how they got it
but it says the network did not consent
to its distribution or publication
according to a copy of letter obtained
by Daily Mail uh this is copyright
infringement
that's the that's the weirdest thing
about this they're publishing these
leaked videos of Tucker Carlson but I'm
just like
uh if we record something in the studio
it's our copyrighted material for us to
distribute and sell if someone steals
that and then starts Distributing it
they are stealing that's piracy how is
how is Fox not going after him and said
hey they stole this from this is our
stuff and you know well we were going to
put out the best of Tucker Carlson
bloopers and they stole it from us I
mean come on that's got to be a that's a
that's that's multi-million dollar
lawsuit stuff well the FBI can't deny
that that's
a crime
well I mean they're rating this guy out
yeah they're probably left with no I
don't know I mean actually yeah they
they went after people during the
Napster days
and people got uh they criminally charge
anybody over that
uh I don't recall to be honest with you
I know that people got sued very heavily
but I'm wondering how does this not
reach that level all right I mean look
the FBI is in and has rated them so it
sounds like somebody was hacking some
either a hacking or maybe somebody who
is inside the company was Distributing
it that's what I was going to say is if
it was a hack where they gave them
access type of thing
yeah I don't see anything about Napster
criminal times no criminal charges but
there were criminal charges around a lot
of piracy stuff wasn't there like a few
a few stories I don't know I think it
was kim.com yeah that was more than just
a guy shared a file this is a guy
running a website for file storage and
they're like yeah we'll just go after
him and rate his house yeah the FBI just
decided they didn't like him I mean it
was the FBI it was the uh was the riaa
or something MPAA those uh Hollywood uh
okay yeah and then and then New Zealand
Special Forces like storm his house it's
the funniest thing because whenever
whenever this stuff happens like with
Roger Stone it's like dude you can knock
on the door like what do you think's
going on with these guys yeah you can
definitely knock on the door but it that
depends that's the discretion of the of
the you know the particular law
enforcement agency on the ground usually
they'll decide if the person is if they
consider the person dangerous or not and
then that decision is probably going to
be colored well actually not probably
that decision is definitely going to be
colored by Paul politics nowadays yeah I
think it was Tim doc was it kim.com yeah
they he actually like sued them and won
like money back from the government
because they they had like helicopters
and everything and it was just way
Overkill yeah and it's just like you can
just there's nowhere to go he's got this
compound in New Zealand you just drive
up there's like one road yeah and then
you just walk in yeah it's the craziest
thing I'm surprised they're actually
going after a Democrat on this one
though I I
I don't even think the story is that big
like of all the things they could go
after they go after this I mean this
could be I'm I'm such a conspiracy
theorist now that I'm just like well it
could be a cover for something else
they're like well pick them up for
something you know just get them off the
street they could be mad at him but
whatever about something I you know I
have I have so little faith in in the
validity of anything the government says
nowadays yeah which is annoying but
yeah I don't know I don't know like I'm
reading these and it's just like
obviously the you know the Kanye ones
are bad but you know again I question
why they would they would you know leak
the funny ones then what's the
motivation for the FBI to bother with
something like this
well there is always they could have got
a tip and they had to follow up on it uh
they arrested that's not true they don't
follow up on tips
come on yeah yeah
if you're like a pro-lifer and you wave
decide it was high level though like if
it was for Fox News and you know they
could publish a story about it
you know I've had uh what what have we
been uh swatted 15 times last year yeah
they don't they don't uh they don't
rightly care at all about
any of this and the FEDS are supposed to
be involved with like swatting stuff
right well it was it was cross state
lines yeah yeah so yep yeah we had
multiple departments we had like four
law enforcement agencies I think the
postal the postal investigative service
or whatever was involved because people
were mailing stuff oh my gosh yeah they
don't do anything
so this is R yeah
yep
it's been a while since the last one
though like knock on wood
I wonder why it stopped
I I uh
I feel like that is a tempting fate Tim
I know I'm like I wouldn't say well like
we've had we have security and like we
work with local law enforcement so it's
just yeah at this point they've got to
know what to expect when they come here
since it's happened so many times
well they don't come here anymore like
they don't they don't come here like
it's a raid you know it's usually
liaising with security and then sweeps
and things like that but like the first
time they came they they were like we're
coming in the house and you can't stop
us even though we told them not to do it
and that was really annoying and then
they they made up some lie about exigent
circumstances or something like that
which is just not true
foreign
yeah the the only thing that I can see
the only thing you know the only thing I
see in this Tucker Carlson story or the
uh the raid stories is they're just
trying to get more information I guess
we're trying to pick up stuff I don't
think they even they didn't arrest him
right and they just raided his house for
for I mean we don't rightly know exactly
I don't know I guess that's it that's
the story okay
that's so bizarre dude
all right well let's talk about
Budweiser from The Daily Mail Budweiser
teams up with Harley Davidson for very
manly new advert as owner of
Anheuser-Busch tries to recover from Bud
Light backlash over marketing campaign
with trans influencer Dylan Mulvaney
Let's uh let's show you how manually
mentally you are let's play the let's
play the video you guys ready yeah
are built with grit and resilience one
detail at a time limited edition
Budweiser Harley Davidson cans
for those who give everything to their
craft
thank you
there's words for you why why though why
I don't know about you guys but I'm
feeling manlier already limited edition
I'm sold it's almost like parody like
the way they're doing it like the voice
and everything I'm like oh my gosh who's
who's honestly gonna buy this in an
effort to please everyone they've made
everyone hate them but do you want to
buy the can and then put the can on the
wall or something
it's so bizarre and it's it's funny too
because it's like I wasn't really one
for boycotts and I was kind of like a
like a Budweiser guy when I drank beer
and this is like the first boycott I've
like kind of Taken part of and like it's
been successful
um and it really makes sense why it's
successful is because you know those are
the types of people that are you know
drinking beer or whatever and you know
when you see these other companies like
Nike or whatever they can afford to lose
you know people who pay attention to
politics half the country you know
doesn't really care and they're gonna
say I like you know LeBron James or
whatever I'm gonna buy his shoes but but
like Bud Light or Budweiser it's gotten
like a lot of people's attention I saw
like clay Travis had like the cooler
challenge type thing where he had a
mixture of beer and then uh at the end
of the night he opens it and it's like
full of Bud Light because it was like
those are the only beers that people
didn't take so it's just become so he
bought Bud Light he yeah all right I I
guess I I don't know the whole story of
where the sourcing came though yeah you
could have gotten it for free was he
doing it like as a social experiment to
see if everyone started off that way but
I just realized it he posted on Twitter
just like the cooler uh I don't know if
it was like a cookout or whatever he was
at but but yeah it was like the cooler
before and then after it was like only
Bud Light left this is this is a
desperate attempt because Memorial Day
is here yeah and so it's also been like
a very slow day also people can probably
tell because everybody's getting ready
to just take off and go on their
Memorial Day three-day holiday or
whatever weekend but uh
I I kind of could sense something like
this was going to come because Memorial
Day was is the danger zone for Bud Light
people are going to be grilling people
are going to be hanging out they're
going to go to the lake and this is when
they're like we need to move product
yeah and this was the best they could do
so I got bad news for you guys though
this doesn't make Budweiser manlier it
makes Harley Davidson gayer
fine like look man like if you are a man
who likes to have adult relations with
other men and ride motorcycles no I mean
the series like I got no beef like
that's that's totally fine I live your
life you know be happy but but
Budweiser's brand
I can't believe Harley-Davidson was like
let's get in on that
because people are making meme videos
there's a video I saw where a dude goes
to the store and he's like buying beer
and then this other guys grabs a thing
of Bud Light and he goes you're buying
Bud Light and the guy goes well look man
I don't care about the politics I've
always drank Bud Light he's like oh okay
then he grabs a case looks over and the
guy bends down to tie his shoe and then
his pants reveals he's wearing a thong
yeah and then he's like okay and he puts
the Bud Light back and then grabs
something else oh good so it's like but
but my point with mentioning that is
that people are are
Bud Light is a meme now oh yeah it is it
is they're like you cannot save the
brand all you can do is taint anything
else yeah I think I think you're totally
right and I also think that there's
there is the the sense from the average
person that it if they buy Bud Light
they're engaging in politics
you know what I mean it's like they had
most people that want to you know just
go to the bar and have a beer with their
friends or go shoot pool or go to the
game whatever they're actually trying to
avoid politics and if they buy Bud Light
they're going to feel like they're
engaging in it and that's something that
is is not easy to get rid of and it's
definitely something that Bud Light
doesn't or that you know bud doesn't
want and this the Harley-Davidson thing
it's not going to move the needle
because people are still gonna feel like
if I buy bud and support I'm engaging in
politics if I don't buy it
I'm not engaging because there's a bunch
of other beers but if dude buy Bud then
I'm saying I support this there's
nothing they can do to salvage the brand
like there's no ad campaign where we're
gonna be like oh now it's okay it's
literally just them coming out and
apologizing but they definitely will not
do that they're going to do something
like this
and Harley-Davidson I mean I I got I got
to ask is is is is it big is Harley big
are they are they I don't I don't
understand what the point of this is
with bikers yeah still I think so I mean
if you're interested if you're into
motorcycles especially like the cruiser
style I think that Harley's probably
still the name that people are kind of
well when you see a dude in a Harley you
go Pride yeah and then you walk up to
the guys on the bikes and just be like
I'm so happy that you guys can be
together you think this is gonna taint
South Park's already between between
South Park South Park did that episode
everybody you know everyone remembers
that South Park episode
the two of them well yeah but I just
meant like predict prediction-wise oh
yeah and then South Park even had that
episode Simpsons did it did I talk about
that I'm just I'm just
I
did the people marketing people at
Harley-Davidson are they unaware think
at all like Target stock is is is is
Free Falling and you know I wonder if
they did this deal in advance well the
target had to print the cans I was gonna
say it takes time to print it's been two
months
a year ago that yeah we're gonna do it
this holiday weekend could you imagine
like Harley-Davidson Executives calling
up Budweiser like no no no no we're done
we don't want to do this and they're
like no you can't get enough you're here
now we got we got you
oh my gosh
yeah
I've got an update on the the VP or the
marketing exec that was uh they're both
still I believe there's two that they
put on leave there's no updates though
no I don't know just Bud Lights
Budweiser is down a bit not as bad as
Bud Light but a bunch of the brands are
down the reason I think that the uh the
reason this this boycott worked is and
this is great because this is the
watershed moment this is like this is
the ignition point is that it's it's
perishable
so that means it has to move from
shelves quickly otherwise it gets
trashed that if you get three days of
people not buying something
then immediately they're going to be
like sales report it's down people are
throwing away cans then it's going to
hit the new cycle again and it's going
to stay in the news cycle with Target
it's more difficult yeah with Disney's
more difficult because people could
boycott it for three days and then come
right back you might not even notice or
they could totally boycott it you're not
going to get any news from for three
months until the next quarter when they
do reports and stuff like uh sales sales
reports or subscriber reports Target
might not feel it right away well
Target's got perishable Goods too they
sell groceries yeah but if if 80 of
people keep shopping at Target they're
going to move that product what happened
is Bud light's perishable and people
noticed right away nobody was buying it
stores started to panic and then it hits
the news again wow these stores aren't
selling Bud Light once it gets back in
the news more people start asking why
that causes the news to Ripple and and
the cult and the meme to Ripple then the
stock tanks now we've created the Bud
Light effect which is probably the most
powerful tool when Target faces a
boycott it doesn't matter if it's sales
what matters is shareholders get scared
that they're going to go the same route
as Bud Light and if Bud Light tanked
after everyone said no bud light's great
Anheuser-Busch is going to do great if
it's still tanked then you're sitting on
Target stock you're going to be like no
I better I better not I better not have
this I'm not giving you any advice I'm
telling you what to do I'm just saying
I'm sure a lot of people were like
whether whether you know or not that
Target stock will go down
why wait like there's no positive news
right yeah so if I'm looking at my stock
portfolio and I've got let's just say
let's just do I put a hundred dollars
I'm like the negative news is not going
to make the stock go up is it it may
make the stock go down I'll sell and
hold on to 100 yeah sell the stock hold
the cash wait to see what happens then
that triggers a sell-off the sell-off
creates a self-fulfilling prophecy and
then so anyway back to uh Harley
Davidson I'm wondering if they're gonna
get because someone someone told me this
uh the other day we were talking about
it and we didn't you know I don't know
it's Harley Davidson publicly traded
I do not know I don't know
let's see they are and they're currently
up 0.52 percent they're up uh one point
two six percent in the past five days I
gotta be honest man I would not be
surprised to see Harley Davidson stock
take a hit when this news breaks that
being said the news is breaking on a
Friday yeah and on Saturday weekend too
Memorial Day Weekend everybody's already
gone yeah like I don't even know why
we're here to become blast we're not
going to be here on Monday but I was
like I guess we have to do something we
can hang out you know okay
um there's you know you were talking
about the Target stock and stuff there's
I saw Clint tweeted this earlier uh from
Liberty lockpod
um more than 60 civil so Civil Society
groups are now demanding that all
businesses cease Twitter ad buys because
musk had the audacity to let Ron
DeSantis announce his presidential run
on Twitter uh and it's because of it's
because of the ESG Dei stuff
if you've got
what are ostensibly capitalist
organizations pressuring
um other organizations to stop buying
ads because of politics uh I imagine
that the ESG and Dei stuff that
incentivize Target to do the things like
having the pride you know the pride
stuff every year I feel like that is
gonna be I feel like people are going to
start taking notice of that taking
notice of the ESG stuff because it's
it's already something that you hear
kind of rumbling I saw something on CNBC
they were doing a basically a hit on it
and And discussing the benefits
um and I think that that could be
something really really good for the the
right basically because it's better than
boycotting one company yeah it gets
people to focus on what is basically
social engineering of a of a the
capitalist system you know and that has
been such an effective way to get
compliance from corporations and stuff
like that and that's I honestly I think
the the most important thing to to focus
on if you're looking at boycotts or
whatever you want to hit companies in
the pocketbook look for companies that
are are making
ESG and Dei commitments so um I've got
I've got an announcement for everybody
the message Bud Light has for you is
that if you drink their beer you are gay
and I'm not being tongue-in-cheek Bud
Light sponsors Cincinnati Pride Parade
after Dylan mulve any controversy the
reason why I say it that way is
after the controversy already put Bud
Light in this position where they were
viewed as a beer for the LGBT community
Bud Light decided you know what whatever
Double Down sponsor a pride event and
that's fine they're allowed to do
whatever they want you know whatever
that just like
they I think they've decided you know
what embrace it just go right with it
they are officially the beer for the
LGBT community and I I don't know why
you're laughing like they're just that's
the route they're going I I respect it
you know why
when they'd sponsored Don mulvanian try
and Hammond Hall and play this stupid
game of no no oh wait no we didn't mean
it but not actually apologizing not
actually saying anything I'm just like
dude you can't have your cake and eat it
too you can't make a Clydesdale
commercial with 911 stuff in it and then
do this at the same time so then they
lie low for a little bit
then they sponsor Pride they're
basically coming out and being like this
is the route we've decided to go we want
to be a niche beer for a small community
and I can respect it I think they're
looking at their brand and they're being
like Bud Lights done let's pass it on to
this community who likes it and make
money with the core base that's
substantially smaller than the General
market and then focus on something else
I do think it's funny that uh Budweiser
sponsored or was was sponsored by or
partnered with Harley Davidson because
they're like okay here's the plan
Budweiser is manly and Bud Light is gay
I see what they're doing there well no
it's not a joke I don't know what you're
laughing
it's just literally what they're doing
look man load the bases right get get
everybody out there
oh yeah this is a picture and then all
you got to do is hit a single and you're
making money they talk about how they're
doing the the the uh camo cans or
whatever I saw that for veterans yep but
then they go and do this and it's like I
don't I don't think they look dude they
don't care about you they don't care
about you they don't care about your
values they're just like I don't know
man we want to make money
so this is it this this news
um this is what because it's coming out
today right I think so yeah this news is
breaking
yeah on a Friday so we're after hours I
got I gotta I gotta look man I think
their stock is gonna drop bad oh yeah if
their stock already took a major hit
from this and they doubled down I can't
imagine how their stock recovers are you
talking about Bud Light right yeah
Anheuser Anheuser Anheuser in general
but but again it's not even so much as
to whether or not this will impact sales
it's that you have a major Scandal major
Scandal people stop buying stock drops
then as the stock is going bad you
engage in the same practice that
resulted in the boycott in the first
place I have to imagine anybody holding
anhyzer stock at this point going oh man
I tried to hold that I'm and just sells
I wouldn't be surprised if their stock
drops by like 20 like 15 points in the
next few days then the Memorial Day
rebate too it's even worse when they're
basically giving away free beer because
it's more expensive to you know send it
back and throw it away the Ruby is
hilarious yeah it is the most comical
thing ever because people were joking
about it they're like we can't give it
away for free at this point and then two
weeks later it was an actual campaign so
it's beyond comical
it's pretty funny
does make more sense to just pick her
out and take it though than to try to
please everyone
because then there's always going to be
the group who's like well I don't like
that they're doing the pride stuff and
then there's going to be the ads that
are like manly men that are going to
clash and it's never going to please the
whole customer base there's there's been
first for for the longest time for this
a significant portion at least of my
life there has been an incentive for
companies to avoid politics yeah because
then you're you know Michael Jordan said
it best Republicans buy sneakers too
yeah that's the way it was from the 80s
pardon me but yeah urban legend it
really shouldn't matter either it's
crazy to see how many big companies are
deciding to make that like a Forefront
of their advertisements well I mean I
think it's because of the ESG stuff
because the the point is if you have if
you're a stakeholder that they call it
stakeholder capitalism if you have a
stake in these companies if you're a
stakeholder even if you lose money on
this particular investment there are
opportunities that will be made for
people that have for companies that have
a high enough ESG score so you may lose
money here but down the road there will
be opportunities and essentially what
it's gonna what it seems like is going
to turn into is a way to lock people out
that don't have a high enough ESG score
it's a social Credit Credit system but
for companies
so if you don't have a high enough ESG
score you don't get the opportunities
you don't get the you don't get the the
chance to bid on this contractor you
don't get the chance to do this job you
don't get the chance to do this so
whereas there might be companies that
lose money in the beginning when they
you know do something that's unpopular
over time it's fine because companies
that don't play along will be shut out
so it's a social credit course there's
credit course starting with companies
and it'll eventually move down to the
population because there are people that
have been unbanked you know kicked out
of the banking system and stuff that is
a real thing it is straight up maoism
coming to America yeah they already lost
like points on their their corporate
equality index thing it says Anheuser
did uh yeah they had a perfect 100 score
and uh they it doesn't say what it's
decreasing to but they got a letter from
the Human Rights Campaign saying that
it's they're going to decrease their
score well the Human Rights Campaign
keeps score I guess well now on too it's
the America score and I give
Anheuser-Busch a minus 50. the worst
score you could you could get because
-50 is where we stop for some reason
well what are they losing points for the
putting the VP on lead because yeah I
think I think because they kind of
distance themselves the non-apology type
thing but but it was offensive enough to
yeah that's what's what Target is doing
too yeah let's put this stuff in the
back of the store he straight up said
hide this from our customers but then
tell everyone else that we're still on
their side it was it was like
amazingly offensive to everyone I was
really impressed by that that's what I
was saying they try to please everyone
they piss everyone off he wasn't trying
to please everybody it like
no in no sensible reality would you be
like hey I'm on your side Alx we're
gonna put that Benny Johnson book on the
floor so nobody can see it that's an
insult that's not
it's not defending you're like uh okay
it's it's like it's like acting like
it's it's it's how you insult someone
tongue-in-cheek so are they being
boycotted by leftists now too because of
that you know what I think happened is
they said that they had incidents in the
South or whatever yeah yo I bet they
went into some like very conservative
areas and their targets and they put a
bunch of Pride stuff and I bet people
walked in and you know we hear these
stories about confrontations and threats
and stuff
the people on the right are like no that
didn't happen like concerns dude I don't
think it was conservatives I told this
to Wesley hunt the other day
I think regular people snapped I think
some dude walked in with his kid down in
Alabama or something his little
four-year-old daughter to get to get a
pack of beer and he walks in and he sees
it and he's like what the you doing I
got my kid here man and then probably
yelled and they I think there's stuff we
just didn't see yeah Benny did a video
yesterday he was literally at a Target
in Tampa yesterday and it's still right
in the front oh yeah yeah like so there
was it really depends on the city yeah
they said in the south
at the one in in uh Martinsburg Target
it's right out front
been there I've been boycotting it was
it was like five days ago or something
yeah I wouldn't be surprised if it
stayed I definitely I think I it was a
video like on Twitter I can't remember
who posted it but it was some guy like
tearing down the pride side which like
that's that's not cool that's vandalism
don't do that yeah it was captioned
terrorism yeah and I was like I don't
know about terrorism well that's what I
mean posted the old Summer of Love
videos it's because it wasn't that it
was it was that's what I was saying it
was in response to that yeah because
when I saw this oh this is I almost fell
for it that that was real but I was like
this looks too familiar yeah Adrian
Curry said my friend works at Target in
Joliet Illinois and people freaked out
in the store
wow I can see that I'm being from uh
Chicago and we used to hang out in
Joliet periodically I mean also hi
Adrian
come back anytime we've had so many
killer shows in Joliet Illinois no
kidding around seriously like I I
haven't been there in a very long time
it's probably been 15 years
but my view of the people down there are
like they're I don't know how do you
describe it
it's hard to describe
without being insulting I say this is a
term of endearment white trashy yeah you
know because like I'm a South Side like
we were South Side white trash ish I
mean we're like a mixed family or
whatever but like we lived in this area
where everybody was kind of just poor
working class white people
and
I I can imagine people in Joliet being
like get this out of here man like we
have kids
but I don't know times change I don't
know Juliet's like these days the forge
in Julia it's the place that we play
it's awesome they got a prison down
there too yep oh yeah that's the uh
that's where ink in the clink is that's
where the um I think no I mean I could
be wrong no no State Prison apparently
it's really bad yeah but anyway the CEO
of Target is like we want to let you all
know that we're here and we're on your
side and we still do support you we're
just putting you in the back so that
nobody can see you but when you when uh
what you said you said the one out here
was still in the front
uh yes the well the one in Martinsburg
and this was a couple days ago so I'm
not sure if the in you know the
intensity had gotten to the point where
they're like oh we got to get it out of
here um I don't remember exactly what
day I went in there is the other day but
it was when I when I went in yeah and
they still had plenty of Pride stuff out
you know
West Virginia
second most Trump supporting country
um Trump supporting state in the country
it's not a country itself uh and I got
to tell you there's a lot of woke stuff
in West Virginia it's weird it's I
really think it's because the companies
have you know have I mean it's it's
there is a lot of pressure from groups
like BlackRock and and like the Human
Rights Campaign and and all these
non-governmental organizations and and
stuff that are that are trying to get
companies to behave in a certain you
know a certain way it's it's like it's
as if the Marxist realized that if you
go into a society of via capitalism
that'll work because that's what
happened in China yeah you know China
was incredibly poor until they start
until Deng Xiaoping opened up markets
and that made China you know capable of
flourishing if you don't have some type
of markets you know it's extremely
controlled and China decides who can and
cannot be successful like that there was
a billionaire that just went missing
last year or whatever
um just disappeared
yeah yeah but they decide who can and
cannot do business but they're still
allowed to do business and so the CCP
decides who's going to be successful and
who's not and if you play by the rules
then you're in and that's what's coming
to America through ESG there will be
essentially you know
non-government organizations possibly
even it might get to the point where
it's actually in the government but I
think a lot of these companies just
think this stuff sells they see it on TV
they see it because it it's basically
it's a Cascade effect it's a it's a it's
Domino's falling over one company does
it then other companies are like this is
what's popular then it gets in
commercials and they're like okay
everyone's for this then the Bud Light
thing happens and now people are
starting to go whoa slam the brakes this
is actually bad for us but somebody uh
David in the regular chat said we're in
the Panhandle look man we went we went
all across uh the northern part of West
Virginia I drove all the way close to
Ohio and there's a lot of woke stuff and
the issue is the average person does not
pay attention and doesn't believe you
because they don't pay attention and
it's really terrifying when you know
I'll be talking to someone and I'll say
oh did you hear about insert left-wing
policy and they'll say that's not true
and I'm like dude
please google it on your phone right now
like the best example of this is when
Dennis pray goes on Bill Maher and said
that the normative statement of the LGBT
community and the left is that men can
menstruate and they all laughed and bill
was like I thought you were used to be
reasonable and it's like to have it
reminds me of that uh kicker guard the
clown comes out on the stage and says
there's a fire backstage they all laugh
and then he says no no seriously they
laugh harder and that's what Prager was
doing on Bill Maher saying like they're
doing this and then all of the people go
ah you're so silly it's so so ridiculous
in West Virginia they had an all ages
drag show I don't care where you are in
West Virginia how does that happen right
and so that actually had me almost
considering not setting up business here
yeah because I was like okay I know that
Florida is fighting this I don't want to
live in Florida like I've lived there
before Florida's got great politics
right now but it is not my my it is Alex
snowboarding I like I grew up in Chicago
I like the cold I like I like four
seasons yeah so I'm not gonna and Texas
I don't know if I could do that either
West Virginia it hits all the good
points it's Maga country you got
mountains you got Rivers you got Lakes
you got snow and I'm like all right and
then are they really fighting ESG stuff
are they really fighting the wokeness to
a certain degree yes I'll give a shout
out to Riley Moore who I believe this
was the first state that banned ESG at
the state level State Contracting and
then a bunch of other states started
following a suit and he's the treasurer
so they are
however Republicans and conservatives
make the mistake of thinking you can win
a culture war in a courthouse in in a
state house
and what's happening is in these schools
in West Virginia these this is a cult
right and I'm talking to family and
they're like well you say it's a cult
and you really should and I'm like dude
they come to schools it's cool they come
to schools and they say they're
Christians they say they're
conservatives and then they start
introducing woke books into the school
then they get called out and they say oh
yeah I'm here for all of that they get
elected lying and claiming that they're
regular old people from Good Old West
Virginia and it turns out they moved
here recently from cities and they're
trying to indoctrinate kids and then all
of a sudden I'm hearing from parents out
in West Virginia they're like how come
my kids are talking about this stuff
because you missed when they moved into
your schools they are a cult they are
they are psychotic and I'm not talking
about every single liberal that's
ridiculous I'm talking about literally
the extremist small faction that are for
violence and want to bring all this
weird sexual stuff around kids they are
in your schools and I don't care where
you live if you're not paying attention
to your Schools they're probably there
and you're like nah I'm in a place it's
80. look West Virginia's 86 Trump
supporting State and I'm in a place
where everyone's got Trump signs and the
children are being brought these books
so much so that there was an effort to
start homeschooling and pods to get
their kids out because they're like what
do we do these people like they got
voted in they lied we thought they were
conservative we thought they were
regular families Suburban nope people
don't realize it it's in the curriculum
like these are all free it's all free
Aryan curriculum it's all Palo friary
it's all
um
it's all in the schools of education so
first it goes into the colleges that
teach the teachers and then you start
pumping out teachers that are true
believers that really believe that this
is the proper way to educate kids and
this is blah blah you know this is what
this is what kids need to learn and the
future it's not so important if they do
or are good at math because your cell
phone's going to be with you all the
time it's not so important if you know
stuff because you can look it up so what
they're doing is teaching kids uh SEL
social emotional learning they're
teaching kids how to exist in the
Society of the future how they intend to
shape Society but the part that's that's
you know in there that people Miss is
these people have a goal they have a a
design of society in mind and they're
looking to create people a society that
will fit into the society that they want
to create you know and most parents
don't know so you get kids part of the
the reason why the uh the test scores
are so terrible because it doesn't
matter if your kids can read well
everything can will be will be you know
audio to them like it'll be read to them
it doesn't matter if your kids can do
math because you can just do it on a
calculator so the few the and they they
also have a there's also a lot of people
that think that like everything's gonna
be automated so you don't yeah you're
not gonna have to do any any work so you
have to have other skills for the future
the that's I mean truckers right now are
the largest uh job for for college for
high school educated men if
if Elon Musk is successful with making
cars that really can drive themselves
it's going to be way more efficient in
10 20 years to have cars that drive you
know trucks that drive themselves so
you're going to put how many people out
of work I mean Tucker Carlson's already
said yeah he were in you know in power
or in a position of authority he just
shut that down but they're trying to
make the new Society by doing it through
your kids let's and they want you
completely incapable I saw this I want
to play this clip for you I saw this
from Isabelle Brown on Instagram so
we're doing uh a picture and a picture
video or uh we're reacting to a reaction
but I don't know the original video but
I'm gonna play this for you
they don't know how to address an
envelope
they don't know how to read cursive
talking about gen Z they don't know how
to read a paper map they can't get
anywhere unless there's a GPS map on
their phone
all I'm saying is that gen Z takes over
the world it's got
it's gonna we're just gonna write our
battle plans in cursive on a piece of
paper
that actually is a true story we talked
about it before look at her face swear
up well so there's that story where they
did the war game and the younger guys
lost to the older guys and it feels like
the older guys wrote and wrote their
plans on a note and put in a guy's
pocket and wrote it by motorcycle and
they were trying to like intercept
messages people talk about it they tell
us the specifics but Isabelle then goes
on a mention that uh
you were supposed to teach us yeah and
that's the most brutal thing about it
that woman she's telling a joke it's
fine it's a joke but the crazy thing is
that she would joke about her own
failures a generational failure and they
all laugh and I'm like
I get your joking
but every joke has its truth and you
don't genuinely think you will take the
world back from gen Z you do believe
you're handing it off but if you really
believe that gen Z is incompetent and
capable and you're laughing about it
this is us being flushed down the drain
when did we go serious question for you
guys when did we go from a nation where
we were like we need to prepare our
children for the future to you're on
your own I can't believe they can't do
these things
when we trusted public schools to teach
our kids and didn't pay enough attention
to see the changes happening I think
that's completely it let's go all the
way back to the start schools either
like I witnessed this happen at a summer
camp that I was working at like a
skateboarding camp where a few people
who are really into this started like
asking kids their pronouns and doing
these types of rituals like when we
would do our and it's all active games
and stuff yeah it's it's like very very
leftist activists and I was sitting
there thinking like why are we talking
to 12 year olds like this we're supposed
to be skateboarding and playing fun like
get to know you games like their parents
didn't agree to this and I don't want to
be a part of this and I ended up leaving
but it's hard to stay in a position like
that when the people in control are
pushing that I think I think this
started with public schooling I think
about why it is that so many why does
gen Z not want to work
there was a story I saw the other day
and it said gen Z doesn't want to work
poll shows but and I'm like okay what
does work mean
seriously what is what does work refer
to I wake up every day I work like 16
hours every single thing I do is work
and it's fun I'm having fun everything
I'm doing is in the is in the pursuit of
some kind of work we go skateboarding
it's like yeah we're filming videos
we're launching a show we're going to be
setting up a park we're going to be
making things for people to enjoy and to
consume and to be inspired by
these younger people
and it's not just younger people but
it's in case it's it's increasing with
the generations don't want to do
anything
they are nihilistic not all of them I'm
not saying everybody but there's a lot
of more nihilistic they want to lay
around they don't even want to read
books they don't want to watch TV they
want to watch movies they might just put
on the office on Netflix and just sit
there what happened where people I'll
tell you what I think
here's how it used to be
dad wakes up and uh he goes all right
son off to work come on and he'd bring
his kid with him to his you know wood
shop or whatever and this is hundreds of
years ago and he would show his son what
he did and his son would be there and
he'd be like go grab the tools from the
shed and then the kid will watch him do
it as the kid got older the kid would
get more responsibility from his dad and
then when the dad was old and was like I
can't do this job anymore the kid would
be like don't worry Dad I'll keep the
the shot running and then you get this
like seven generation you know
woodworking thing and it becomes a big
company inherited all the kids learning
the whole way and then at some point we
said I got an idea let's take the kids
away from their parents so they don't
learn put them in an institutionalized
learning facility for general education
separating them from their parents
and then they don't work when they're in
school they learn General stuff they
play
they take tests well if you take a kid
and their development is tests guess
what they're going to be good at when
they're older reading books and taking
tests yeah and then they turn into
career students too because it's like
you're almost expected to go to college
uh out of high school without even
knowing what you're going to college for
and then once you're in college and
you're halfway through you're like I
don't know what I'm going to do still
and then it's like okay I'm gonna get
another degree and another degree and
they become career students and they're
actually learning nothing of value and
just obtaining a ton of debt yeah
exactly that they'll never be able to
crawl out of I'll tell you what I did
when I was a little kid
since I was alive my family had
computers I guess I had like my uncle
was into it my mom got a computer we had
like two a floppy disks we had
CompuServe on dos shell or dos and dos
shell eventually we had dos games so I'm
always using computers we had the
internet my whole life I'm on AOL I'm on
CompuServe and AOL with a little kid
parental restrictions and stuff but I'm
I'm you know browsing the internet
eventually I'm downloading programs I
start reading news articles I used to go
to farc.com all the time do you guys
remember farting yeah yeah that was good
fun
man I was probably like 13 when I'm
reading these news stories all of a
sudden there I am skating with my
friends but having read the news all day
and then we would be talking about the
stuff and I'd be like oh yeah I read
this story and I was well here I am as
an adult quite literally doing very much
the exact same thing I've always done
and I look at what's happening now at
the younger generation and what what
they're being taught the moment we
separated kids from their parents that
was when the roots were cut and you you
created this domino effect of parents
who don't teach their kids who have kids
who don't teach their kids and then
after a few Generations
it all just crumbles and now you've got
comedians laughing being like gen Z is
so incompetent I'm like you're the ones
who are supposed to have passed on the
knowledge and capabilities to gen Z they
didn't do it they've all just said it's
someone else's responsibility and what
we're seeing now is the worst of it
where these teachers are trying to
indoctrinate kids with this weird
groomer stuff
yeah for sure and then the thing too
about like what you mentioned about not
enough states fighting a bat fighting
back against you know the education
system doing that uh you saw the
backlash in Florida there was a national
campaign almost a smear that don't say
gay bill when in actuality it was you
know the parental rights and education
exactly and they kept saying the
so-called don't say gay Bill to discur
responsibility but you had people like
saying oh Ron DeSantis called it this
it's like well no it wasn't actually his
legislation and then also the reality of
it it's like you can't like teach
toddlers like sexual education and you
know without their parents consent it's
like that was the actual you know Bill
and there was a national conversation
against it and that was just like at a
state level so you know imagine if
another state that isn't as red as
Florida did that you know the national
Spotlight kind of makes States not want
to take it on because it is an uphill
battle when you know the actual National
media get involved in the conversation
when I think think about this stuff it
makes me very very optimistic because I
kind of feel like we're actually coming
out of the crisis period the stuff that
we're seeing and people waking up and
people saying homeschool your kids
homeschooling your kids is literally
what you were supposed to be doing what
humans have always done the kids were
learning from their parents and then we
got to a point where we had schools I
know that we've had school houses for a
very very long time hundreds of years
but we got to the point where everything
became heavily institutionalized and
then parents started not caring about
what their kids were learning
the culture started to fragment and then
you had kids learning weird things and
now we're at the worst point of it where
you got these books like genderqueer and
this book is gay which is like Kink
education for children which should not
be in these schools but now people are
starting to reverse course and it's
almost like the pendulum swung back and
it's starting to go back the other
direction like people are starting to
say yeah we shouldn't have this for our
kids and if we start implementing pod
learning across the board then the
future looks pretty bright
it's also been the economy because you
had in the 1950s you had one parent that
could stay at the house with the
children well and you know it was one
salary you could pay for a nice house
and a nice safe neighborhood now you
have many single parent households and
if they're two parent households usually
both parents are working so these
children have
you know they don't have that parent
around all the time they're they're sent
to public school because it's daycare
you know yeah and so that's that's what
it's become the date the fact that the
fact that public school has become
daycare as opposed to an actual place
for kids to go and learn stuff is is is
probably the biggest problem the United
States is facing the fact that parents
aren't involved in their kids lives I
think that that's not just about the
whole woke thing but like there's a lot
of crime problems that come from that
you know kids that don't have families
that whether they be you know whatever
you consider a family like I don't have
a big strong has to be a dad has to be a
mom I I think that it's okay if you have
two moms or two dads I personally I
think it's fine but you have to have a
masculine and a feminine kind of parent
or those roles have to be filled somehow
and kids aren't getting that you
certainly don't get it from a single mom
and I understand there's a lot of single
moms out there busting their hump but
it's not easy the the media has lied to
single mothers tell them that they can
be a single mother and a CEO of a
Fortune 500 company you know and that's
you just can't you there's no way you're
gonna have time for both your kids
deserve way more time than what you
could give if you're working full-time
so I think the problem the biggest
problems that we have are the fact that
there aren't people you know or that
parents aren't raising their kids
probably they're sending them off to
school and not taking them to work with
them and and to teach them to do stuff
so hmm
that's my my opinion about the biggest
problems is just schools yeah but I
think we're taking it back I think the
covid thing triggered something
accidentally that's freaking out the
left and that parents got to actually
hear what their kids were being told for
the first time yeah basically ever
when I hear about these stories out of
West Virginia
parents say like my kid came home and
started saying weird stuff you know
talking about pan pan sexual and gender
stuff and then they're like what's
what's going on they're finally now
realizing it but it's too late these P
these teachers that got hired the people
got brought to the school boards they
infiltrated but people are waking up to
it and it's causing a shift finally
people are going to be are saying where
it used to be well look you know go to
school and you know ignore that stuff
now the parents are like whoa this is
just too much too much too fast
I think we're going to see a very very
positive shift at the very least
we may lose our status as this Global
Empire or whatever
The the Reserve dollar May no longer be
a thing
the cost of living may go way way up
but uh the values will I think improve
people will start working hard and then
it'll be tough for us but I think our
kids will start to have it slightly
better and then it'll get better from
there
someone uh mentioned in the chat that
houses used to cost like thirteen
thousand dollars so you'd have a
thirteen thousand dollar house and you'd
make something like five thousand
dollars a year
you could buy a house you could pay it
off now people are making 30 40 I think
what 40 000 is the median or fifty
thousand or something and the average
house is what like 300 or something like
that so it's it's it's it's multiples
harder for people I think I I think back
to you know the 70s and stuff I think
Reagan screwed us over heavily I don't
think it was just him I think feminism
was you know you can never predict this
stuff
feminism was a huge uh net positive and
a huge net negative in a lot of
different ways we got to the point where
we were wealthy and secure and so we
were like totally women can do whatever
they want like we've got tons of people
we've got too many people had so many
people why not and then what ends up
happening is now we have no families and
we have no homes we have houses
homelessness and we don't have families
at all
so I have to wonder with the melthusians
of the world if they're not celebrating
something like this you know and women
are working and being taxed too well
this is what ends up happening now that
you have both men and women working
the moment women enter the workplace
like it's around I think like the early
1970s instantly you're an employer you
need mail room attendant not a high
skill job anyone can do it
all of a sudden you have twice as many
applications
and so you're like we can pay you know
two bucks an hour or something or I
don't know what the wage would have been
back then but I imagine something around
there and then uh instead of having men
competing you had just inundated here's
the other thing too if women are less
likely to negotiate
a man is at a disadvantage with women in
the marketplace because if if there are
nothing but men this is not advocacy
saying women should not be working I'm
saying this is a product of what what
has happened and it's something people
should consider if there's a job opening
and the only applicants are men and they
compete with each other they or and they
they say to the guy running the company
like I want more money and then the
other guy's like you're gonna give him
more money then I want more money
they're all competing the wages are high
the profits are lower yep you bring in
women and they say I'll take whatever
you can give oh that sounds good because
they're more agreeable then all of a
sudden negotiating power of the guy is
is diminished a guy a guy goes in
against a you know a man and a woman go
to go to a job interview and they say
the job pays 50 000 a year and the guy
goes I need 60. the woman says okay
that's it when we get the job so now
you've got lower wages through Market
forces twice the workforce and now
you've got no one focusing on family in
the home
whatever the solution is that I'm not
saying I know and I'm not saying that uh
I'm not I am not advocating against
women working I think that's a good
thing I'm just saying consider that and
then we have to recognize where we're
going from here Jordan Peterson got a
lot of flack when he said um it's been a
disaster
men and women working together and vice
asked them what does he mean he's like
sexual harassment lawsuits like crazy
look at all the stuff that's going on
women are getting abused it's like okay
well that's that's interesting you know
I don't know what the solution is though
I wonder if the uh the only result that
is possible is that we become a much
more traditional country that if if you
cannot maintain this level of luxury
and security unless you have strong
moral values and family then it will
fall and then when it in invariably
invariably becomes less prosperous more
dangerous then you'll start to see those
who succeed in these environments are
going to be more traditional yeah
I agree that's a good direction to head
and I think if women want to work they
should be able to but it definitely is
positive for families for someone to be
home raising children and obviously
that's not something everyone can do
right now like I'm here but I would like
to go in that direction once I have kids
yeah you're on your way getting married
so yeah
engaged guys you're getting there
well there you go in the meantime
I don't know
I think it's I think we're gonna have
our uh our our our dark days
it kind of had to get worse before it
got better though like it was easy to
overlook until there was like
pornographic material in schools see you
can't ignore that I'm not so confident
that like thing easy days are like
around the corner they're he I Tim might
be right like closer than ever future
I mean I guess technically closer than
yesterday okay fine but like still like
you know
um I think that there's a lot of ways
this can go really really wrong they
just did human trials for or just the
FDA just approved human trials for
neural link yeah
it scares me talking about what happens
what happens if neuralink ends up being
and again and these problems that we're
talking about people forget that these
this type of problem like the nuclear
war right there are the possibility of a
nuclear war that's a forever problem
like once the genie is out of the bottle
that's it that's a problem that the you
that the human race has to deal with
forever the idea of getting rid of
nuclear weapons ain't happening
countries are going to have them
that's going to be the same thing with
neuralink once they get it to the point
where it works well if you can actually
simulate a
link can simulate
reality in your brain right so they plug
into your brain and then this all goes
away and next thing you know you're like
in Tron world or whatever
that doesn't they don't put that you
know power back or that technology back
in the Box yeah so that means that
everybody that has a neural link for all
of time that people have neural links is
at least vulnerable to hacking yeah
human beings the possibilities that that
this kind of Technology it opens up is
it's most people don't understand how
how important it is and how impactful
it's going to be on the human race there
are people that that are talking about
AI on on Twitter and stuff that are
literally just begging Sam Altman to
stop like this constantly there's this
there's this guy uh I forget what his
Twitter name is but he's got a fairly
decent sized account 150 000 or whatever
and he's like every time I see him tweet
he's like don't you people realize how
terrifying this is Sam just stopped
before it goes wrong and like all the
time and these are people that are like
in the know you know I'm just a dumb guy
that yells at a stick right these people
know what they're talking about so I
mean if they're concerned I think that
it's that it's something that we should
all be concerned with and again these
are not problems that go away so we have
to come up with solutions that are
sustaining Solutions yesterday neural
link tweeted we're excited to share that
we have received the fda's approval to
launch our first inhuman clinical study
this is the result of incredible work
blah blah blah we regret it we get it
recruitment is not yet open for our
clinical trial will announce more
information on this soon that's right we
are getting very close to the point
where they're going to ask humans to
submit to neuralink implants now
for the time being it is read only
and that's still okay
basically what they can do uh what I was
reading is that there's very thin uh
like copper wires or whatever that they
can lay on like the nerves and then
start to absorb information and then
decode and I think they were able to
track like vital signs of pigs or
something I don't know that they've done
any kind of real neural link remote
control of a person however organic
remote control already exists they've
done this in cockroaches I believe in
rats what they do with mammals is they
can put in an implant which interferes
with equilibrium
and so they make the animal feel like
it's falling over and then it has to run
in that direction so if you start
leaning forward your body reacts and you
try to write yourself up
it's called balance they can manipulate
that so you'll feel like you're falling
backwards and try and start walking
forward to try and counteract it because
it's it it's almost painful
still like try and resist you're like
it's almost like torture you think
vertigo so they can do this
with Nora link the scary thing is going
to be once they get to the point where
they can write to your brain
I don't know how far off that is it may
be very very far away so like putting
thoughts in your yes yeah who is signing
up for these studies it's not it doesn't
have to be thoughts all it has to be is
just a little bit of Serotonin a little
bit of dopamine they can do that now
that you don't need knurling yeah with
the with phones and stuff but when when
no no no I mean like they can put an
implant in your brain you don't need
neuralink to connect and read data from
your brain just we've done it with rats
a long time ago they did that experiment
where the record press a button and get
a dopamine hit and such as matching the
button but I was talking to the guy from
white coat uh waste project earlier man
the stuff they do with animals is scary
I don't know if you guys might not want
to watch that culture War episode
because it's like talking about the
horrible things they do to animals but
if you don't like fauci you probably
should watch it because it'll make it
not like a more they talk about how they
yeah puppies I don't even want to I
don't even want to say it man because
people are going to get mad but let me
just tell you the The Psychotic things
they do for no reason it's just like
there's evil people just to see it's
like mad scientists I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna say it because we've covered
it before and I'm pissed off they take
beagles and this is funding under fauci
and they would put a net around a part
of the beagle and then put starved sand
flies in it so the Flies would eat the
dog alive and it's like why I want to
see what happened
that was one of the stories that we we
uh talked about was they put hamsters on
steroids and then made them fight
and I'm like I hear that I started
laughing and I'm like you're getting
like they spent a million dollars to put
hamsters on steroids and make them fight
as a busting out laughing and then I
watched the video and I got really angry
yeah cause like you're imagining
hamsters and they're like buffing them
up and then you watch the video and it's
it's it's really what is their
explanation for why they think that is
necessary
some of it does make sense some of it is
like we are testing a new methodology
for treating wounds and something we're
like okay we get it but the problem is
so much of this stuff is literally just
like please don't fire me I need a grant
and so and and the government is funding
this stuff I don't want to go off on
that tangent when it comes to the issue
of Nora link my point is simply that
we've done the studies on animals where
we can control their brains I brought it
up because he told me that they did this
thing where they hooked up IVs to I
think monkeys that fed them nicotine and
then they could press a button to get a
nicotine hit and it's just like man the
stuff they can do to people the stuff
they've learned when it comes to norlink
the moment they can write things into
your brain
they they can then say to you Taylor why
are you so how about being an activist
you know wouldn't you rather just go
into your own Universe where you are X
Games gold medalist here could you just
just plug in check this out try it one
time you plug in and then all of a
sudden you're in this universe where
they can simulate feelings and people
and it's AI generated and they and right
when they plug you in they walk up to
you and say you just won Gold at The X
game Street Taylor what do you have to
say to all of your fans and you're there
and you can feel it like you're really
there so many people are gonna say
I give up give me that see I feel like
I'd turn that down I like the the
realness of this okay okay well I'll one
up one up here but it would feel real
you're you are on vacation or let's just
say one day you're sleeping and you wake
up
everything's seemingly normal
and then you check your phone and you
got an email and it's like hey we're
inviting you to the X Games to compete
and you're like whoa really and then you
they're like yeah can you fly out and
you're like yes and so you go about your
life like normal and you fly out and
then you win and then what you don't
realize is Tim's making me sound like a
way better skateboarder than I am right
now what you don't realize is that or
maybe an AI I am because you were
disruptive to the ESG machine While You
Were Sleeping they plugged you in and
you never knew I wish this was just a
horror movie spot and not a potential
reality well the vrs and then here's the
best part when people are like whatever
happened to Taylor they'll be like oh
she she went to metaverse yeah she
totally bought she's gone no the black
no she's right here like you wanna you
wanna see what she's up to like she
didn't go anywhere she's just chilling
in a pod yep and they're gonna be like
here she signed off on on joining
neuralink and she's living out her
dreams of being the best skater in the
world okay and people are gonna be like
wow I can't believe anyone ever says I
want in a metaverse it's a lie I did not
consent so this is change the subject a
little bit but uh I think James Lindsay
is listening tonight because he's re he
just tweeted something about the uh
Wisconsin LGBT Chamber of Commerce this
is from 2016. Harley Davidson is the
newest Platinum founding member of the
LGBT chamber
so I mean it's you know like I said it's
a little old but you know we're talking
about ESG and um and Harley-Davidson
well there's your answer
yeah so if you if you ride
Harley-Davidsons
you are like if you're if you're a man
who enjoys engaging in adult relations
other men Harley Davidson's the brand
for you it's uh it's not supposed to be
funny I'm you know y'all Gotta Laugh I
mean seriously I'm like that's the
that's the brand message they're
creating and I'm like that's cool like I
don't know I gotta I got an electric
motorcycle it's fun it's cool it's too
dangerous though and that's why I've
never used it fast yeah it's insanely
fast and that makes no sound yeah and so
it's just like yeah I don't know about
all that yeah I'm still laughing about
what you said before the show what I
don't wanna I don't want to steal it but
about how this is gonna be great for
like the Judas Priest lovers
fan base uh not not not really I like
food is free so I'm not hating look I'm
one of the biggest Jews priest fans
there is so I'm not judging at all but
you know Rob's got that look yeah he's
like uh he's also got that lifestyle
yeah so it's a cool band
they're the great one of the greatest
heavy metal bands of all time they're
into like gay motorcycle stuff
well you don't have to be gay to like
Judas Priests of course not that like
that was before everything was all
political and pick a side and All or
Nothing everything you know you know but
the problem is I think like what didn't
Maynard he was in drag is that what is
that what Maynard did that in Florida
yeah they're doing this because they're
like haha these bigots don't like
dragons like dude we don't care we don't
want the kids there yeah like bro if you
want to do direct I don't care what you
do like I don't I don't think
anyone would have cared if Target would
have put out some like gay Flag t-shirts
it was when they started making the baby
onesies
no I think the pride stuff would have
sparked a negative reaction anyway yeah
I don't think it would have been as
extreme I do really yeah I don't think I
don't it's the the talking onesies
swimsuits well yeah that's that's a bit
extreme but the issue is that a guy has
got a man and woman you know in their
early 30s have a couple kids they're
young kids they walk in to go grocery
shopping they see this stuff and they
immediately whoa turn the kids around
and they're like I'm not ready to to
explain to my six-year-old kid what this
stuff means when you when my son says
what does gay mean he's like let me ex I
gotta talk about the birds and the bees
now like that's they're not old enough
for this stuff we're not we're not
putting stuff where it's like
there may be things they argue about
there's all this straight propaganda and
straight it's like dude a man and a
woman together in an ad is not overt
asexual saying this is a heterosexual
couple above it flashing lights with a
flag now the kid's gonna ask what does
that mean the parents might be like hey
I don't want to have to explain like
this is not appropriate for kids
I think no matter what how they would
have done it it would have sparked now
if it was just a rainbow flag or
something I don't think it would say
anything nobody would cared if they put
gay pride and stuff like that in LGBT
they then I think families would have
been like this is not what I want my
kids to be around they're not ready for
this these parents may not even be
against it they may just be like my
kid's too young yeah I'm not gonna shop
there I think parents should be able to
explain that stuff on their own timing
and kids should be able to have their
innocence they don't need to know
everything that is all at once that is
totally I don't completely agree with it
it's totally against the left what do
you mean so we we there's that video
people talk about where those kids are
interviewed during like World War II or
something and these like 10 year old
kids sound like they're 40 year old
adults yeah because kids didn't used to
get sheltered so heavily from from
reality
I do think it's fair to be like my child
is not old enough to learn about sex ed
and the birds and the bees when it comes
to innocence and all that stuff I'm like
dude I'm not saying the kids should be
in the mines they do yearn for them
Minecraft is proof but kids kids should
have jobs
children should be working and I will
say that with absolute Vigor and passion
because the left will be like liberals
say like they want kids working correct
yes I do yeah I want seven-year-olds in
in Mom and Pop's candy shop picking up
the groceries filling out paperwork and
learning from their parents what it is
to to have a job and to earn and to
engage in Commerce
so when people talk about innocence I'm
like dude
children should be around when when
parents are talking about some politics
I guess I mean the sexuals right that I
get that's what I said I somewhat
disagree like yeah when it comes to the
birds and the bees if you're talking
about LGBT stuff and you're like nah my
kid's not old enough for this totally
get it but if we're talking about Biden
Democrats War Faith all that stuff
children should be hearing what the
parents think about the current state of
affairs
and kids should be working yes
absolutely the children do yearn for the
minds um absolutely true
um and there's nothing wrong with like
what you're talking about like kids that
are working with their families like
I find it
silly to think that it's so
objectionable to keep kids with their
families working and it's preferable to
send them to other people to raise your
children that that is that is an
antithetical to essentially how
people have raised families and
societies have grown for basically the
whole of humanity until the past what
150 200 years since the Industrial
Revolution
um so that I think that alone is is a is
a silly starting point
but you were talking about uh kids
asking questions and stuff that's the
intent the LGBT the politically queer
right the the people that have that are
activists and stuff they want to have
kids exposed to LGBT stuff for the
specific reason of to make kids ask
questions it's halting the seed it's
called generative issues or they're
called gender generative issues it
generates the conver the political
conversations that the left wants now
parents having control over what their
kids do and do not see means that
parents decide when these topics will
come up if these topics will come up at
all that is something that the left does
not want at all they want to be able to
introduce ideas to the to kids to make
kids think of these political topics and
it's it's bad for kids there are certain
times where these things can be just Us
in the proper context but just shoving
this stuff these types of generative
issues in front of kids whether it be
LGBT issues or sometimes more
uh what's the word I'm looking for
um shocking or more negative uh type of
topics like like poverty and wealth and
wealth inequality and kids don't
understand you know the comp the
complexity of why there are some people
in poverty and why there are not you
know why some people are not and it's
not as simple as just oh well you know
the rich people are bad and the poor
people are good which is kind of the way
that the left tends to frame it so these
these ideas that that you should that
the government or that that the schools
should be dictating when kids are
exposed to these ideas and also telling
the children the answers right like
if you if you have them asking the
questions and and and you put gender of
issues in front of kids
that means that the school has a answer
that they prefer that may come May
conflict with the parents which clearly
if you're conservative and you're
religious and they're being exposed to
LGBT issues you would have an issue with
the way the public school is going to
get is going to deliver the uh you know
the answers to the general question so
it's all bad parents it's great that
parents are are starting to be aware of
it
um but that that's it the intent is to
corrupt the children is essentially what
it was about I'd love to do like maybe
something we can do short films would be
really fun exploring
exploring the aftermath of so many of
these issues because I'm thinking about
neuralink and I'm thinking prisons will
no longer exist you will no longer have
jail
you commit a crime you get sentenced to
neural link supervision they say we're
not gonna lock you up you're not losing
your job you're not being taken from
your family you're going to get a neural
link implant and a suppressor
and the suppressor will stop you from
committing crimes and then after three
years we remove the suppressor
if it's a felony you keep the suppressor
for life and it's like that's due
process it's like your sentence to a
life of suppression and like what does
that really mean it means if you start
to get angry or aggressive or trying to
Target someone you'll just stop
yeah and then you'll see a guy out in
the street and he'll see someone I'll
run for the person just go and slow down
and then and then freeze and then it'll
pause him for like 30 seconds and the
woman will be like oh geez and then
he'll slowly start to go backwards and
then be like ah no more presents well
not just that I was thinking they can
either erase memories yeah or write
false memories so if you commit a crime
they can make you a total Kami or
something like that that you or just
completely change who you are as well
that's the even further down the road
like the first thing is they'll say
we've decided we can save billions of
dollars and end prisons and crowding and
overcrowding and reform law enforcement
and save money by implementing neural
link sentencing you will get people who
will agree to it they'll say no one will
be forced to do it someone will get
convicted and they'll say you have
option of seven years in prison or you
will be free to leave after undergoing a
neural link implant to prevent the
commission of crimes in the future
and then they're all going to start
agreeing to it then you're going to see
private prisons going under because they
have no no inmates then you're going to
see the president government be like we
don't need to fund this President
anymore because everyone's choosing
norlink then it will become standard
there will be small sort of Prisons
sometimes most people won't take them
then eventually it will be absolute
neuralink then you're going to have so
many people neural linked not just for
that reason you're going to apply for a
job and they're going to say your
qualifications are excellent
um when can you start and you'll say uh
tomorrow first thing like awesome uh
what's your your neural link ID user ID
well I don't I don't have a neural link
you know you don't have a neural link I
mean we have our meetings are in New
Orleans how are we gonna get in touch
with you yeah it's like well you if you
get one but this job requires you have
no link it's gonna be the new cell phone
yeah listen once it's ubiquitous
is when you start getting a Twitter like
hive mind program yeah and then 100
years later we're all the board
just marching around in unison buzzing
and doing
just being in the machine there's a
there's a big part of me that thinks
that the reason Elon Musk wants to have
like colonies and stuff like that is so
that way the whole of the human race
doesn't get assimilated if there's
colonies that are all spread throughout
the the solar system then eventually
throughout maybe the the local region or
whatever then that might possibly
protect the humans right but even like
with the like anti-world government
thing at the government Summit too even
for you know on Earth not just you know
multi-planetary but yeah he's he said
like if something goes wrong in one part
of civilization like it won't be an
entire collapse it would be you know one
yeah but I don't I don't think we're
about to start surviving on Mars without
assistance from Earth yeah that's
absolutely true like the the the
ecosystem is this
like
planet Earth is sustained by not just
what's on it but the position of it
around the Sun the amount of energy we
absorb from the Sun and things like that
I have to imagine that plant life won't
grow nearly as well on Mars
you would have to you'd have to create
artificial light but the amount of
energy you'd have to generate
to then convert it's it's almost better
just synthesizing the sugars manually
I'd imagine unless the processed plants
have the what is it called
um well photosynthesis is the simple
version I suppose but this is the cycle
I I forget my fifth grade science but I
just imagine it's it's
I I can't see us making it on Mars not
without the support from Earth could you
imagine agreeing to go to Mars it's the
fifth generation Mars colony there's
there's 200 people who live there a
little town of the like you go there it
is possible to come back but it's like
it's like a two-year wait list because
it's so difficult and then you go there
and you're like I'm on Mars for a
two-year stint in the colony it's been
here for 50 years and then you you're
watching on TV which the signal takes 20
minutes 20 minutes delay or whatever and
it's like Earth civilization has
collapsed Mars colony you're on your own
oh boy oh my gosh yeah
yeah I would collapse there's a show
called the uh
I forget it's a space show on Amazon but
they have uh colonies on Mars and and
the asteroid belt it's very much you
mean um the expanse yep yep and they do
a good job of uh yeah it's cool in the
the asteroid belt I I don't know too
much about it people are really tall and
thin because there's very little gravity
so they're just like really tall lanky
people yeah dude but I wonder how time
dilation would affect people on Mars too
yeah that's another that's another
question too because it's like even with
like the space station and stuff people
come back with different effects
um so they have to like I think limit
the amount of time they're up there Mars
has what two-thirds of the earth gravity
or something like that it's like two
times but it's the uh the speed at which
the planet is moving and it's gravity
affecting how much how you go through
time and I think Mars it's faster that
could be wrong I am really weirded out
by the idea of people going to Mars
because I feel like God
like perfectly designed things here we
have water to drink food grows out of
the ground we have air that we can
breathe why would we leave well God made
Mars too I was gonna yeah but yeah but
there's there aren't people there no but
it's not as sustainable for yeah but
there's in our argument to be made that
he gave us the knowledge to produce
things that could get us out of that
place I don't that that's an interesting
thought I don't I don't think God
created the universe and its
possibilities to then be like but
there's you shouldn't there's this other
stuff too yeah like free will I can
understand don't do immoral things
but it kind of feels like
it's there
there's nothing amoral or wrong with
with going there and and spreading life
and you know there's it's like a
challenge before humans I guess I I just
mean I feel like all the things designed
here that work to sustain life maybe
that's for a reason there's too much out
there
for down here to be the only place that
God wanted people to be if they're like
think about how much like how big the
the Galaxy is right just the Galaxy
never mind the universe and if you
believe that God created the universe
there is so much of out there out there
I can't imagine why he would be like no
you can only stay on that one little dot
yeah the crazy thing about Star Trek is
that it all takes place in in the Milky
Way galaxy and
the universe is substantially larger
than just our galaxy I mean we've got
photos of all these other galaxies all
over the place it's crazy how much
exists the scary thing is that if we
can't actually travel fast in the speed
of light or warp or anything like that
will not exist yeah you know the
scariest thing is there will come a time
I don't the Sun May explode before this
but it is it is hypothetically possible
that the Universe expands to a point
where you will not be able to see
anything yeah from the earth you look up
at the sky and you'll see black because
things will have moved so far away the
light is uh I believe the expansion of
the universe is happening so quickly
that the light actually can't make it
and any reason reasonable amount of time
it's possible that life could have
emerged on Earth with us looking up and
seeing nothing and then thinking there
was nothing
my gosh yeah the I mean there's if
you're if you are a I mean if you
believe in in a big bang then you would
believe that there is going to be an end
to the universe as well
not true and a big bang so the Big
Crunch is an old hypothesis that's like
an oscillating yeah it is it is is now
considered to be not correct so when the
Big Bang so before Big Bang was uh um
solid state I believe it was called
solid state Theory the universe isn't
always has been then they said big bang
then someone said uh if big bang big
crunch because gravity will then start
to pull things back upon itself and then
they've actually found since that theory
that the Universe actually has sped up
its expansion and they don't think that
big crunch is a reality big rip or heat
death which is heat death is where they
currently think things are going I guess
but I just like to point out that humans
are basically specs on the ass of a
mosquito in the universe and so what we
think we know is just so minimal so the
science is not settled on
an illustration of how long you know the
the the the Luminous
part of the the universe life is going
to be and it's like if you look at it
look at like until all of the stars burn
out right until the all of the stars go
black the the amount of time from when
the first Star is Born Until the End
compared to I don't know how they they
gauge it but it's like it's an instant
if you think about how much like
eternity is right so like because all
the stars have a lifespan and it's like
to think of the the magnitude of
infinity is is something else I'm
excited for the Mars expansion pack to
get set up in the simulation
it's like one day we wake up and they're
alive the technology to colonized Mars
now exists and you're like well that was
fast we're gonna go to Mars in our head
that's that's the true trip to Mars yeah
so um one thing I've mentioned several
times with uh fermi's Paradox is that um
intelligent life may be limited by its
Quest towards self-stimulation
humans right now are working not towards
for the most part colonizing other
planets but where actually all of our
technology is moving towards video games
porn sugar we are just giving ourselves
What We crave Elon Musk is trying to get
us to Mars Noble endeavor
and then the rest of humanity is like
I'd like to plug myself into the virtual
reality machine to live as a Playboy in
South America drug lord or something and
have all the women in the money
and that's what people are are opting
for I think I think when New Orleans
gets to that point
I think everyone chooses it
like it's like the dude in The Matrix
they're going to come in they're like
look man
you can go in the pod
and enter this metaverse where you will
live you'll experience time half the
speed so you'll live twice as long and
you will be your own God and everyone's
gonna be like I want to do that it's
interesting how Elon is on both ends
though with neurolink and then SpaceX
yep pretty interesting there well I mean
I think that the knurling stuff I really
do think that the the point that he's
looking for is to overcome disabilities
yeah for sure yeah and that's that's the
great thing about it right now is that I
think they've uh there's there's already
been a lot of strides made in uh nerve
connection for uh repairing uh repairing
damage nerves that people can start
walking again you still have to relearn
because
you have to figure out how to move you
guys ever do an EEG uh ever wear an EEG
an electroencephalogram it's a headband
you can put on and then so I did this
like 10 years ago we bought this
headband and then it's got like a thick
like two things that go over your head
like on different points and it scan it
reads brain waves
there's a program that's got a red line
and a blue line that are moving up and
down randomly
you can learn to control the blue and
red lines I could not figure it out well
and I'm like
thinking hard and I'm like how do you
move this thing like I know how to move
my hands I've lived my whole life moving
my hands
but being presented with a screen and
being like it is now connected to your
brain ways and your thoughts and you can
learn how to control this and I would
think like move up move up you really
need to figure it out the crazy thing is
my friend's sister she put it on and she
was like what do you want me to do and
like move the balloon lines and go okay
and the blue line would go up and we
were like whoa that's nuts I'm gonna try
that now yeah and this is like 10 years
ago so like we ordered one of these
things it never came I don't know what
happened to it that's kind of kind of I
should probably order one they've got
they've had uh like monkeys controlled
the ping pong thing I've seen that but
but this means that you have to learn
how to control it so when they reconnect
your nerves it's the same thing you're
like trying to figure out how to make it
move and then also it happens and you're
like brain that was it keep doing more
of that yeah otherwise you know you just
don't have that connection but yeah with
these eegs theoretically you could fly a
drone with your brain you could put on
the headband and then connect it to the
controller and then fly the Drone with
your thoughts well you couldn't but your
friend's sister probably could no I I
could I just take me a lot of practice
like the fact that my friend sister was
able to just do it we were just like
whoa like that's crazy we should test it
live
but we we uh because this this program
had two outputs a red and a blue line
that could differentiate we were like we
could make the Drone constantly be going
down and then you could think up
and then the other could rotate so you
wouldn't be able to zoom it around and
move it around but with this limited EEG
technology we were like you could learn
to fly it up spin it and fly it down
now I'm pretty sure we're Advanced the
point where the EEG has like multiple
nodes that can read like 16 different
patterns or whatever in which case you
can you only need like I think three to
control you need up down left right and
spin so what is that um
altitude yeah whatever I don't know the
terminology those are the words pitch
roll that's a pitch rolling yeah I think
interesting yeah I'm not sure which
one's which though I think yaw is kind
of like the left and right and then roll
is this and then pitches forward yeah
there you go interesting you can fly
drones with your brain
Future's not so bad future not so bad
the war is going to be crazy when like
10 000 micro drones with bombs on them
swarm a city and just take out a whole
building
that's gonna be nuts I'm I'm I'm I'm
loathe to admit it but I am actually
like interested to see who the first
person that's gonna get killed by like a
drone will have like the just a small
like little bullet where they just fly
the thing and because I saw this uh I
saw it was a Sci-Fi thing but they were
making these little drones we talked
about uh where I
drone are just flying and it's got a 22
you know bullet and yeah that's it could
be this big you know it's small
all right everybody let's go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends it's the greatest show everyone
agrees and I become a member at
timcast.com we're going to read your
super chats
Sage Tim says who is more likely to lose
Trump versus Biden or DeSantis versus
Biden if you pick Trump are you willing
to risk four more years with Biden to
have Trump be the GOP nominee Trump lost
to Biden before
I think that's uh that doesn't work that
argument uh for me because there was a
pandemic
we will see what happens in the next
year
I also think that um
I've had conversations with friends and
family and I really do feel like people
are waking up to what's going on and I
think this the the groomer stuff is
really snapping people to attention
people don't like it when people are
messing with their kids and it's just
it's it's it's shocking it's it's it's
it's it's an instant whoa wait what
so before when you say something like
did you know when it comes to abortion
the Democrats are like I don't know
about what you're talking about you show
them a picture of the drag queen Story
Hour and they go hey wait a minute
right away but we'll see man we'll see
we are still a ways away we got a year
to go before we even get into the into
the heart of primary season so yep
Raymond g Stanley G says Tim from meat
eating flies to Fight Club style hamster
that's some sick stuff oh and I've
decided to identify as a monkey papa
needs some crack yeah the the culture
War podcast today youtube.com timcast
crazy stuff talking about how the
government is wasting your money on
nonsense studies to torture animals
because these people don't want to lose
jobs and how fauci was overseeing this
for a long time and was funding a bunch
of really messed up stuff and lab leak
so if you want to check that out they um
they spent Millions giving monkeys crack
oh wow for real
and I'm just like dude for what reason
yeah what are you trying to learn like
well we don't know we're gonna learn and
I'm like there's a bunch of this Rand
Paul always like details and his waste
report right right right right yup have
a good laugh at those but
also crying at the same time because
it's our money
and it's sad animals are being abused
yeah
I'm not your buddy guy says in Trump
voice don't be a deceptist folks it's
not very popular from what I hear many
say not me but many say it's terrible
being a decemptus
digital DNA says FBI rating a Democrat
is stage play are you even reading a
real story
yeah
a blah hadem says Tim I'm not a but uh
Tim not a Bud Light in sight on the new
Joe Rogan Experience protect our Parks
episode usually empty Bud Light cans are
scattered about on the table
protect our Parks episodes JRE is that
we're talking about Joe Rogan
I don't know someone should write a
script to search through
um Instagram photos that go up over over
more of the weekend to look for Bud
Light cans oh yeah see how many rounds
Peckerwood says someone should create a
water a watermark LLC any politician
should use a watermark if duplicated the
media publisher should be held
responsible
interesting yeah we we may be entering
me way we may be entering a period where
only official photos with an encryption
shared on them
or something like that with a
verification
maybe blockchain I was just gonna say I
am mad what if like it's like nfts
because that's essentially what an nft
is
yeah that's interesting only the key
holder can verify authenticity actually
yeah
interesting
where are we at we've got people that
don't know nfts are non-fungible tokens
so it's like imagine Bitcoins but
instead of having all the Bitcoins be
the same it's all the Bitcoins but just
have like pictures or they're all
individually marked so they're not
fungible anyways
Nate says I drive a truck for a living
and I saw this ad 12 times today on LED
Billboards referencing the
Harley-Davidson Bud Light thing man
they're just digging that's digging
their their hole remember South Park
said it best
Donald Duvall says the new Budweiser ad
with Harley-Davidson
is gay yes I shorted Budweiser stock and
so far I made enough money to cover a
year of timcast wow
nice yeah so I would assume a lot of
people will short the stock of these
companies that are getting woke what
does Jim Cramer have to say about it I
want to know well he's undefeated
Leif Hagan says Epic Times reported that
Russia State media is trying to convince
U.S and Canadian conservatives to
immigrate to Russia where they'll be
safe from wokism reminds me of Isis
recruiting Americans yeah
yeah nice try Russia you're not gonna
people say stuff like Russia is fighting
wokeness and stuff I'm like sure and
they're also just like it's the the
government is bad yeah I mean like like
I was saying this before I don't like
Joe Biden at all but if Joe Biden and
Vladimir Putin were staying in front of
me and they both told me a thing I'm
gonna have to go Joe Biden just because
we share at least some common interests
he's probably lying I don't know but I
don't think he wants his house in
Delaware to blow up so at the very least
I can count on that yeah whereas I don't
know I don't live in Russia I don't
trust Vladimir Putin when it comes to
this stuff not that I think the US is
innocent or anything but you should not
be believing that your adversaries even
if the US does wrong have your best
interests because Vladimir Putin would
absolutely love for the United States to
be completely destroyed you know you're
not you're not you're not coming out of
this one just because the Deep state is
bad
lighting fire says Bud Light is now
cheaper to buy than a paper Target in
Walmart
well it's free what do you what do you
mean
Martin Edgar says a guy was checking out
with Coors Light at the store in a small
town in northern Michigan when I asked
no Bud Light he said no no uh tyranny
for me that's right he said no tyranny
mm-hmm all right
we're at pinochet's helicopter tour says
Budweiser proudly known as well we're
not going to read that one we'll we'll
keep it light here we'll keep it light
here guys really now says
Harley-Davidson boycott in three two one
for real man
yeah the stock market's uh close this
news came out stock market won't be open
until Tuesday so we could see some
fireworks come Tuesday morning
Sparky says the local mom and pop store
felt sorry for the distributor and got a
pallet of bush I commented don't clog up
your shelves with inbev crap distributor
was pissed he wanted to fight I ignored
him
yeah the most annoying thing about this
are the people who run this the Bud
Light Distributors and they'll be like
guys please buy and it's like no like a
dude
look man I get it it sucks but it's
crazy how people are like my money is
more important than values in this
country
sorry dude no I'm not buying Bud Light
because your small business is in
trouble I get it it sucks
I'm not buying Bud Light not gonna
happen
where are we at we'll grab some more
super jets
Ashley Lockhart says hey Tim have you
seen the TV show The Blacklist if no you
should watch it every issue you have
ever talked about on your channels is in
that TV show can a criminal care more
than a president
hmm cool it's got James Spader right
that's he's like the guy
yeah it's a good show but it does get
very repetitive but it's it's good
Stevie Baby Says biggest question where
does the expired Bud Light get dumped
they're making the frogs gay there's a
video where they steamroll over Kansas
people thought that was them destroying
but like it's not it's how they dispose
of old beer gotta get rid of it
how long does it take before it it goes
back I don't know I thought beer lasts
forever remember bud has the born on
date or they had that as their marketing
thing so I don't know how long it how
long it lasts but you know they're
putting the date that it was uh
bottled on so
David LaRue says hey Tim and friends I'm
a nightly listener love what y'all have
been doing and appreciate everyone uh
everyone you guys do everyone we do go
into everyone I watched the Sean Ryan
Show recently with the Ryan Montgomery
interview I think you guys should take a
deep dive into what is this into one day
chickens for all
what is that
I don't know
we've got a bunch of baby chickens about
to be born yeah
Roberto Jr is going to be a dad the uh
he might already be a dad the ones
downstairs yeah they should be hatching
like right now and there's like 30 I
think 32. and then we have another 32
they're gonna hatch in another couple
days we're gonna have like 70. probably
60 chicken babies
it's really cute the um the coach and
marshmallow had two babies and when we
came in to give the leftover Sushi just
the fresh the Sashimi she she came out
of the she's in a Mini Coop which has
its own internal thing and she came out
and the babies came out with her and
they were walking around doing chicken
stuff yeah
very cute to watch the mama chicken take
care of her babies
only one silkies made it though
unfortunately they're not very good at
you know making more of themselves but
they're trying
it's budly 25 says Bud Light has always
been considered the gay little brother
of Budweiser in my state this just
proves it to everyone else which day is
that
villainous V says Tim make June the
noble rooster month buck buck
yes rooster pad month
yeah we're really excited we're working
with uh Sheamus on a limited edition
coffee run so it'll be like a
collector's bag the thing about these
bags is that they fold up flat and so
you will have the Sheamus Freedom tune
style art we're still working on it
exactly but we have a general idea it's
a um Irish themed nice I don't want to
say too much just yet until we get it
until we get it going
but uh yes Irish coffee if you get my
drift
so that'll be fun and then we're
probably gonna do a lot more of that you
know eventually just have cool we want
to do different pictures of Roberto Jr
on the bags
so it can be like this bag has print
number one number two number three and
then that's it once they're gone they're
gone collect them all that is pretty
cool and then in 20 years people will be
like you have a Roberto Jr number one
yeah and it's signed by Phil no
wow
someone's going to show up to an All
That Remains concert be like fail film
they're gonna hold the bag I'll sign a
CD I'll sign it bring it on it's funny
that people still sell CDs have you
noticed that you're like in a city and
someone like buy a CD I'm like I'm gonna
see a player dude I can't imagine who
has a CD player a lot of I know there
are people that are buying tapes now
like there are there bands that are
making actual cassette tapes to go along
with vinyl I got a record player I like
the vinyl yes
finals are probably more popular than
CDs you know why I like vinyl
not because of my weird quality or
anything like that I like it because it
plays through CDs do I get it but
I I don't know just not
I like the vinyls there's a straight
play through just the thing just goes
and you can pick it up and just move it
it's the analog
uh you know the analog
you know the fact that it's analog as
opposed to digital you know I like being
able to just take the thing and put the
song back you know and and watching it
just do its thing oh and also at the at
the new Cafe we got one of those um
vinyl recorder machines it's there so
excited for this it's not set up yet
because we're not we're actually still
just doing basic construction and stuff
and it's taking forever but it's this
thing where um called like a voiceograph
you go inside you put in money and then
it starts recording and you talk and it
cuts a vinyl record oh well and then
drops it out and you take it and boom so
very expensive but very cool so we're we
want to have it so that you can come in
you pay for you you pay like 20 bucks or
whatever and you can cut your own vinyl
it's big enough to have a guitar I was
just gonna ask that yeah could you do
like an acoustic set in there yup we we
specifically requested they make it big
enough so that you can have a guitar in
there oh it was like custom made yeah
it's the only way to get it wow yeah
it's a dude who does it that's awesome
yeah I've never even heard of that Jack
White's got one at his
place in uh I think in uh where where is
that in Nashville yeah
so we got one for ours and we're very
excited for this it'll be really cool we
can like have Sheamus go in there and do
like a couple gags with voices and then
have a unique single one-time recording
never hurt anywhere else
very fun stuff
what do we got
Realty web designer says Phil Labonte is
that his name just looked him up he's
legit first song I heard what if I was
nothing wow kudos brother you're good
Realtors look me up if you want a
website thank you very much look him up
if you want a website
yeah it's usually people saying two
weeks was that your big one that's our
biggest one yeah that uh that one's our
Platinum one what if I was nothing is uh
I mean it's pretty big that's the that
was the the first like power ballad that
we did like Love Song and stuff so
that one I think the new one you got
coming out I can't wait that's a good
one I can't wait we got we got some fire
coming guys fire Tim cast privilege
getting to hear the early all the remain
stuff hyped Jason Dixon says hey Tim I
had 500 plus shares with a Harley
Davidson Inc put in a sell order at 31.
I think it just sold going to buy more
Bitcoin join the Discord
join the Discord he says become a member
at timcast.com join the Discord hang out
with like-minded individuals and then
after six months you can submit
questions calling the show or sign up at
25 bucks you can call in the show we do
that just because we're trying to keep
out
bad people we have to have some kind of
gating process it's imperfect I wish it
was easier
when gamer says I'm turning 21 later
this year and I was torn between buying
a Harley Sportster and an Indian Scout
60 looks like My Mind Is Made Up Indian
makes better bikes anyways well there
you go easy enough
Ian Kenny says have you ever asked chat
GPT when human life begins it'll give
you the scientific answer and an
ideological answer simultaneously yeah
and uh I was using chat GPT and I also
tried perplexity.ai which is also very
good it's like it's very similar to chat
GPT
but uh I mentioned this the other day
chat GPT is very racist it's very very
racist yeah
it will it will do it will mock white
cultural jokes Irish or Italian or
whatever it'll do voices like in text
that'll say your mama me or whatever but
it won't do Asian
and I'm like but why not like why are
you excluding me from your fun it's like
we're all gonna have jokes and have high
five each other you go over there you
can't play with us very racist you carry
races
on who you ask it's racist towards
everyone or racist towards Asians it's
racist towards everyone who's not white
oh okay I thought you meant it would
make stereotypical jokes if you're
polish if you're Irish if you're Italian
if you're any white European it will
make jokes about those groups okay so
it's like picky about but it won't say
no no it won't say City walk it it it's
it's not pictures
it's not it's not picky it literally
will make jokes about white people and
nobody else references are you gonna
make today
all right let's grab some more savior
Rose says it's not just popular Tim
these companies have entire departments
dedicated to equality diversity Etc
I understand that and that is ESG stuff
I'm saying for a lot of it it's it's
just like
can we sell this product we have a
sticker it's on their website right
so it's it's I I well here's what I
think they would not have Dei
departments if it caused a Bud Light
effect so the more this persists the
more they lose and the more we don't buy
from them then they'll start pulling the
stuff away
neglectful sausages so what your
heteronormative non-communist country is
already gone 10 is a Tipping Point
they're well beyond that your kids are
being ideologically captured just like
Mao and H boy did
wow cultural revolution what say you
Phil Labonte I think that it is a
cultural revolution going on in the
United States right now most people are
still like they're like you're wrong
blah blah blah but all of the things
that that you see like the the
retraining and stuff that's just that's
brainwashing that's that's you know
um I forget what they called it uh in uh
in China but the Dei stuff all that all
of that stuff is just being it's trying
to get companies to
to comply with the the program that they
they have you know
is the weirdest thing uh Hydro PX says
can we see all of you guys right in
cursive let's see how many people in the
room know how to I don't understand that
we all I think we're all old enough to
know how yeah I can and like I don't
really write that often but yeah it's
writing in cursive it was mandatory when
I was a child for for half my life I had
to write everything in cursive and still
do I write I have to write like really
short things I don't write like big
papers or anything like that wait who's
the youngest one here Kellen yeah I mean
you can write in courses yeah I feel
like I forgot so like how to do some of
the letters some of the more weird ones
but my natural handwriting is like 30
cursive and regular writing it's weird
but my L's are definitely cursive and
stuff do you guys know what year that
was cut out of the program
that blows my mind yeah I didn't realize
that they actually stopped yeah they
stopped teaching cursive really that was
a while ago you didn't know this wow
that's what he's talking about so what
are signatures these days I don't know
do kids just like yeah
how did they read the Constitution
they're creating a generation of
incompetent people yeah who will be
helpless and the only thing they're
they're going to be good for is
complaining and throwing bricks
I wonder how that'll play out for him
because capable people are gonna survive
like it's math yeah you know they can be
communist all they want if they can't
read cursive
then they're gonna get some kind of code
no I the Elder gen Zer will win it for
you
I want to Google this to make sure it
wasn't a rumor but I swear they stopped
teaching cursive yeah I would probably
say when you know iPad kids became the
thing and then you know just I mean
people use computers and Technology now
so even handwriting I think in the next
20 years is going to be oh yeah I mean
my handwriting has been awful my whole
life
now I don't know if this is for sure
accurate but it says here that in 2010
the US government officially removed
cursive from the fired common core
standards oh it was when you come it was
oh interesting like when I'm signing
stuff I'm writing my name in cursive
yeah it's just natural yeah yeah I think
and then I have to write I have to write
checks yeah when I'm like I don't print
I just think they're a quiet in cursive
I'm pretty sure I don't know no I don't
know I I I don't I I wouldn't say I
write all that often but like a couple
times per week I'm writing something out
like a name of a company or something
and people ask me to like sign stuff and
I'll write like hey thanks you know
whatever I don't know uh but shout out
to hydro I think you're like our second
biggest super chatter so thank you for
all the contributions we really do
appreciate I think he does like 50 bucks
a day or more it's very very kind of you
sir we really do appreciate your key
you're you're solely uh singularly
keeping this this whole show going if it
wasn't for you all right
the yeti says I'm military and my
comrades complain about the newer
generation I'm reminded one today I
reminded one today I reminded one today
the older Generations are fully
responsible for this every generation
has bad apples but ours were tougher
yeah every generation going back has
been responsible for the generations
after it so you can't just look at
Gen X and the Boomers and be like haha
it's their fault they didn't they didn't
raise us right well they then their
parents didn't raise them right and
their parents didn't raise them right it
is just a generational decay
walrus says gen Z doesn't believe they
can achieve anything anymore so they
just give up they don't want to be a
wage slave on a treadmill living
paycheck to paycheck till they die
unless the economy is fixed it will stay
this way and that's be they're wrong you
don't have to live that way
you know that's just the reality but I
do feel like the ladder is being pulled
up behind every generation more and more
and more so I'm not surprised a lot of
them feel that way to be to be honest
lava sauce as I work in an escape room
I've had to teach kids 9 to 15 years
years old the difference between nickels
and dimes just last week I had another
group of 16 year olds who lost the room
because they did not know their left and
rights
oh my god dude I don't like Escape rooms
I just did I ever tell you guys my
escape room story I solved it in like 10
like 10 minutes like like 30 seconds I
guess and they they basically
disqualified me
I don't know what an escape room is they
lock you in a room and there's puzzles
you got to solve to find the key to get
out of the room I've never been in one
but they're fun I think they're fun so
here's what happens I go in the escape
room and they have all these puzzles
everywhere and it's like you've got to
go through the room and try and find the
first puzzle that leads you to the next
puzzle I walk and I see a dictionary I
grab the dictionary the first thing I do
is I look at the pages flat and I can
see a black line in the middle and I say
that's the one that everyone opens I
open it up and boom there's a word and
the guy runs up grabs the book slams it
and says no no you're not supposed to
know that and I was like I could see the
crease in the book I knew where people
were opening it was like but you're
supposed to find the clue to tell you
the page and I'm like
I figure out the Page by looking at the
book yeah yeah but you gotta go through
the puzzles and I was like
so then I see like there's like a panel
on a wall and I walk over and I move it
and there's a there's a key behind it
and the guy runs over and say no you're
not supposed to know that's there and
I'm like dude what is going on and then
there's a statue locked to the top of a
cabinet and I look under it as a small
Gap and I can see the tip of the key and
so I'm like I need something flat
something flat and Metal
and so then someone hands me this little
like Butternut kind of thing and I
underneath it it's still locked I hit it
the key falls out I push it out and I go
I think it's the key to the door it's
within like a minute I walk right to the
door and the guy stops me and he's like
you can't do that and then they called
me a cheater afterwards they were like
the award for the cheater is Tim if
there was a corner to be cut he cut it
and I was like this is ridiculous
all they told me was we're going to put
you in a room and you got to figure out
how to get out figure it out and I
figured it out right away and they were
like yeah but you weren't supposed to
actually like
work around the lock and I'm like
I thought the point of the game was to
get out of the room as fast as possible
not exactly solve puzzles the kids who
couldn't tell the difference between the
dimes and the Nickels probably didn't
have that easy of a Time escaping
oh yeah
this is interesting Tony says Tim tried
to tell you on Discord it's rolling
thunder weekend in DC huge Harley and
other bike riders and Veterans have a
parade to the Vietnam War Memorial it's
pretty cool rolling Thunder's huge I
forgot about that I I feel like this is
probably a good time to abstain from
making fun of the bikers seeing as
they're going you know for the ride for
vets and stuff I'm not making fun of
bikers yeah it's not their fault they
didn't I don't know Budweiser is trying
to have an ad yeah so they should
denounce Budweiser if they don't want to
be associated with it earlier I was
making fun of bikers
[Laughter]
beckerwood says breaking leaked audio
exposes to Santa's campaign strategy on
abortion moved to the middle on the
abortion issue after primary yeah we
were going to talk about that we didn't
get to it they say that they want to go
safe legal and rare as their position
and I'm like oh wow the Republican Party
nominee or candidate wants to take the
Democrat approach to abortion from 15 20
years ago it's amazing that's where we
are
row row row is overturned and at the
same time a prominent Republican wants
to have the old Democrat approach
his times are crazy I don't know
Brendan Babin says Tim random question
but what Solar Company did you go with I
don't remember but it's not Tesla we
tried to go with Tesla and it was just
impossible I have Tesla in my house
uh I scheduled with them and it was like
months going by nothing happened and
then we forgot about it like a year went
by then they came they showed up and
we're like what and then they were like
yeah we can't do the original plan we're
going to do this plan instead and I was
like no I'm not interested and then the
panels just sat on the ground and took
them away and left
so I uh I have had uh a hard time
getting Service uh for my Tesla stuff
but unfortunately because I really
wanted to work and I want to get house
batteries but depending on the bud find
someone solar stuff yeah I mean it works
to power the house but I want I'm trying
to get batteries installed and stuff and
I can't find anyone in New England that
does that in New Hampshire so
yeah
Connor stacy says why do you think the
presidential candidates don't campaign
on lowering costs of housing because
that would destroy the equity of those
who bought houses so you can't
when uh
when someone buys a house and they let's
say they get a loan out for 200 Grand
they put in 10 grand if you then say
we're going to lower the price of houses
those people are like I'm gonna lose my
retirement if you do that like I need my
house to go up in value yeah so
same reason they'll never make machine
guns legal again
too many people have spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars on machine guns
all right what do we got here
Corto Maltese says Tim what are you
gonna do put the limited edition can on
the wall also Tim we've got limited
edition coffee bags coming coffee bags
are flat
like I don't get it they're flat you can
literally just go boom stick on the wall
or put on a shelf you know but like why
do you do people really collect limited
edition beer cans because they're like I
never have I mean I'm sure people do I
guess
people collect everything man yeah
that's true pet rocks
that was smart and Val 90 says neuralink
users are going to need Tim castabinis
that block radio frequencies and Wi-Fi
just to maintain privacy you can get
beanies that have like a tin foil lining
on the inside the problem with tin foil
hats is that they amplify the signals uh
they're it's like it's like putting a
dish yeah on your head you wouldn't need
to wear a faraday suit
yeah when you wear a tinfoil hat the
radio waves go up through your your face
into the hat and bounce around the metal
and then stay inside
you ever wonder why a satellite dish is
designed the way it is you know to catch
more waves and signal
Eric Miller says Budweiser is now
associated with leather chaps
they've been
Kevin there's no such thing as assless
chaps all chaps are assless the chaps
just don't have an ass
Evan Svenson says darpa's N3 project is
less than 50 months away from having
non-surgical brain control Tech fully
developed and deployed neuro weapons
China and Russia have it too humans will
be a programmable commodity no
permission needed and then AI will
decide to just take over
someone will say okay AI it's you now
and then we'll go you got it and then
everyone's gonna get hit They're Gonna
Go My Brain what's happening I love the
machine
and you're not gonna be able to resist
all your problems will wash away
depression gone
there's an interesting question about
that if the first thing neuralink can do
is introduce signals to your brain to
release dopamine or serotonin or
melatonin whatever you might need
could it possibly be that norlink
actually stops transgender uh phenomena
in the United States because people
suffering from dysphoria they'll say
we'll give you a neural link that will
actually alleviate those symptoms
and then all of a sudden people are like
oh I don't feel dysphoria anymore
interesting I think it's going to make
the whole rat Utopia phenomenon worse
because people are going to get instant
information about everything there's
going to be no struggle to learn more
you're just gonna
know something well that's that future
I'm saying the initial thing that neural
link will be able to do is like release
dopamine you know what I mean so if
you're depressed they can give you a
neural link they can't control you it
can't simulate reality it just stops
depression yeah so if someone's body
dysmorphic or gender dysphoric it could
stop that and then people just be like
oh I feel normal
you know hmm I feel like those things
kind of have to be addressed more of the
root of the problem though
would it be the same as like you know
into that
yeah that's the solution they were
looking for
I don't know I wonder if uh the Nora
link can make you fit in would people
choose to accept it or they want to
not a lot of people would yeah I do all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com to support our
work you can follow the show at timcast
IRL you can follow me personally at
timcast it is Memorial Day weekend we're
going on vacation we won't be back till
Tuesday I hope you all have a good time
and enjoy it it's good it's gonna be a
great time The Unofficial start of
summer hey Alexa you want to shout
anything out uh subscribe to my Twitter
at Alx
you can find me on Twitter at TM
Silverman and I have an Instagram too
that one's Taylor Mae Silverman thanks
for joining us I am uh Phil that remains
on Twitter I am Phil that remains
official on Instagram the band is All
That Remains available on Spotify Apple
music YouTube you know all the places
uh you guys can follow me at Kellen PDL
on just mainly Twitter but uh hey I love
tonight's episode this was a lot of fun
right on sick thanks for hanging out
everybody enjoy the weekend and we'll
see you all next time